consider Margaret Sanger Margaret Sanger
the patron saint of Planned Parenthood
who's taught as a wonderful American in
schools there's a bust of her in the
Smithsonian I believe Margaret Sanger
well the most wicked women in American
history talking about statues that
should come down no one no one ever
seems to tear down her statue Margaret
Sanger offered a substantive moral
vision about abortion about life that is
perverse it's exactly the opposite of
reality but listen listen to her vision
for life not so different than the CC P
the Chinese Communist Party not so
different from the left today do you
believe in sin when I say believe I
don't need to believe in committing sin
do you believe there is such a thing as
a sin I think the greatest sit in the
world is bringing children into the
world but have we disease from their
parents that have no chance in the world
to be a human being
practically delinquents prisoners all
sorts of things just mark but they're
born that to me is the greatest in the
people can have become commit but sin in
the ordinary sense that we regard it do
you believe or do you not do you believe
it infidelity is a sin well I'm not
going to specify but I think it's in
that state but I think it's the worst
thing yes then you ask me to say what
and like and I said what and I and you
refuse to answer me
I don't know about infidelity it has so
many personalities to it and what
person's own belief is you can't I
couldn't generalize any of those things
consider the perversity of that this is
one of the great heroes of the American
left and and really you know consider
the great hero of Planned Parenthood she
says that the worst sin in the world is
letting people live the worst sin in the
world is not killing people and then the
interviewer Mike Wallace says what about
all the sins that we consider sins you
know like you know violating the Ten
Commandments that sort of that
adulteries oh I don't know about that I
can't talk about adultery well of course
not because if for this woman the
highest virtue is killing people I
suppose the highest virtue for her would
be consent to do all of these terrible
things she is offering I mean it truly a
satanic vision of the world saying the
the worst thing
to his light human beings live but that
isn't moral vision we need to oppose
that with an opposite moral vision if we
don't do that then we then we are
consenting to the left running roughshod
over the whole culture and frankly we
deserve what we get if we're not willing
to actually stand up and oppose it this
video is sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description